the intellectual roots of critical
thinking
can be traced back to 350 bc the first
one to embrace critical thinking
practices was the famous greek
philosopher socrates
he was obsessed with the notion that
many people were basing their ideologies
on an empty rhetoric
rather than sane and rational thinking
confused meanings
contradictory beliefs biases and
self-delusion
formed the foundation of their
argumentation and socrates was
constantly questioning such practices
he also had an aversion towards
authority because he believed that a
person in power
doesn't necessarily possess sound
knowledge and insight
he might just be a good manipulator and
performer
socrates method of revealing
unreasonable argumentation
is called socratic questioning and
epitomizes the idea of clarity
and logical consistency his approach was
later on adopted by plato
aristotle and the greek skeptics all of
whom shared the belief that
things might be different than they
appear and that the critical mind should
read between the lines to establish a
reasonable truth
the ancient greek philosophers were the
forefathers of the
critical thinking movement and
influenced the work of other unknown
thinkers like
francis bacon nicola machavelli isaac
newton
adam smith and emmanuel kant
what is logic well logic comes from the
greek word logos
which means reason so logic and reason
are strongly related
actually a brief definition of logic
would be something along the lines of
the study of the principles of correct
reasoning
logic is the force that can give an
argument the impetus it requires
in order to prevail logic is free of
emotion
and it deals with information in its
purest form
logic is truth and truth is logic now we
can't really understand logic as a whole
if we don't investigate the two main
reasoning methods used
in order to reach a logical conclusion
deductive
and inductive reasoning deductive
reasoning is used when i try to apply
information i find
in a specific set to any member of that
set for example
bachelors are unmarried men bill is
unmarried
therefore bill is a bachelor as you can
see deductive reasoning is very specific
and it doesn't leave room for ambiguity
that's why deductive reasoning is
associated with formal logic
formal logic focuses mainly on the
validity of the conclusion produced
it is the most appropriate form of logic
because it follows rules and compels us
to adopt a more
fact-based approach in our narrative
deductive reasoning in formal logic
can be represented as follows every a is
a b
some c's are a's therefore some c's
are b's as long as the premise we use to
represent the variables a
b and c is true the conclusion some c's
are b's will always follow
if the conclusion doesn't follow the
argument is invalid
inductive reasoning on the other hand
uses explicit data
in order to create a bigger and more
generalized judgment
for example yesterday you left home for
work at 8am
and arrived on time today you left home
for work at
8am and arrived on time so tomorrow if
you leave home for work at 8am
you will arrive on time inductive
reasoning is associated with informal
logic
that's the most popular form of logic
because it is the one we use in our
day-to-day lives
i also consider it the most critical one
to self-examine because
once you manage to understand the
mistakes you do in that subset
you will improve your critical thinking
immensely
as you can see the main problem with
informal logic is the generalization
included
you cannot form solid conclusions and
assert opinions
when your facts are predicated on
arbitrary information
the reason you will encounter informal
logic in your everyday interactions
is because it's kind of practical
meaning that it helps us make decisions
faster
but also because of logical fallacies
logical fallacies are errors in
reasoning that
stem from a plethora of factors some
examples include ad hominem which is
latin for
to the person or man that is when
someone attacks the person and not the
argument
it is the most common form of logical
fallacy because it is the most personal
one
stereotyping that's also a common one
and it is usually
bolstered in difficult times when
emotion takes over reason in social
discourse
faulty sampling when we use the wrong
set of data to form a conclusion
like the example before about time and
work false dilemma
when we try to oversimplify and use
binary logic in complex dilemmas
especially when someone tries to explain
something as black or white
and the truth is actually gray post hoc
ergo propter hawk which is latin for
after this therefore because of this
certain forms of prejudice fall into
this category especially
when we don't feel lucky or things don't
go as planned
for example every time i wash my car it
rains
for me arguing is a waste of creative
energy and i try to avoid it
the problem is that we live in a very
unstable and polarized world
and arguing sometimes is inevitable
sometimes you just need to argue because
you need to fight for the right cause
below is a personal equation i have
developed over the years after
analyzing debates and interviews of
various philosophers
thinkers politicians and activists
argument winning equals facts
plus frame plus eloquence let's analyze
each element separately
so facts are important because people
will always treasure the truth over
assumptions
if truth is very difficult to define
focus on the most popular norm
for instance we don't know how the
universe was created but the big bang
theory is quite acceptable at this point
in time
usually the most popular sources of
facts are science publications
statistics and also material where you
can find things
the opposing party has stated in order
to rebut their views
one could argue that some publications
and statistics serve certain interests
but
as soon as they can't prove that one can
always use this body of knowledge to
one's advantage
the most interesting thing about frame
and the reason why people usually favor
it so much is because
it communicates resilience and character
during an argument
one of the parties will attempt to use
personal attacks in order to gain the
upper hand
this will inevitably lead to
emotionality and emotionality is the
enemy of critical thinking and proper
argumentation
especially during political debates most
of the candidates lose because
they can't really handle personal
attacks in an attempt to balance the
attack
they become emotional and the other
candidate suddenly looks more suitable
for the role
the best way to deal with a personal
attack is either to counter attack
fiercely
or to reframe the argument into
something that you consider more
favorable for you
so a fierce attack example would be if
candidate a
would say something like you are not
suitable for the role because of
lack of experience and candidate b could
answer
you did x in your personal life you
can't be trusted by your own people
how can we trust you to run our country
and the reframing example could be
if candidate a would say again you're
not suitable for the role because of
lack of experience
and candidate b could answer i have
enough experience
and i want to see this country prosper
and flourish even more
we are in this together and i fight for
the american people
the only thing you fight for is personal
power we don't need that
we're better than that we want more than
that
politics aside i wouldn't suggest using
these tactics with friends
and these are methods used by famous
people in order to increase their
influence
arguments in personal relationships
usually lead to friction and problems
empathy is the best way to deal with
disagreements in the social sphere
and also trying to promote reason above
everything
finally bear in mind that arguments
aren't always a bad thing
we tend to condemn arguing because we're
related to immensely unpleasant
situations the truth is that debates can
be extremely civilized and
if both parties have an open mind they
can gain a lot from a heated discussion
eloquence is optional but sometimes it
can really affect the way you are
perceived by your environment
using big words usually disorients the
other party and
if you are having a debate in front of a
crowd you will definitely be perceived
as more
knowledgeable and persuasive eloquence
is probably the most difficult of the
three skills to cultivate
it requires practice and constant
exposure to unknown words and phrases
in order for your brain to become
accustomed to them if you really want to
cultivate this skill
i would suggest following eloquent
speakers like sam harris or
allende bottom and also reading hard
books while doing so try and keep a
record of words you like in order to
revisit them from time to time and
eventually entrance them in your
vocabulary
critical thinking apart from the main
benefits it offers in
one's social and professional life it
also serves as a useful tool when it
comes to decision making
whenever you face a difficult decision
and you need to approach a topic from
many angles
you need to employ critical thinking in
order to ensure the most
optimal result for that process i have
developed a three-part method that
promotes
a holistic approach to critical decision
making
the decision you are facing will be
subject to many factors thus
open to many interpretations let's
assume that you want to vote for a
specific candidate
how are you going to investigate whether
or not this candidate is really the best
choice
what's the news what's youtube videos
read blog posts
that's what most people do but when it
comes to critical thinking
that is not enough investigating a topic
from a holistic perspective
requires that we go deeper deeper
usually means that
you need to read relevant history do a
background check
investigate policies suggested and also
look into opposing views
why might there be critics is the
criticism legitimate
is the critic qualified eventually by
gathering all that information
you will be able to form a more sound
understanding of the concept in question
reading about specific topics is not
really enough
in order to understand the topic deeply
you need to test it and re-evaluate it
based on scrutiny and skepticism learn
to discuss the topic with other fellow
thinkers
online and offline in order to form a
solid and confident view
understand the implication of your
choice and realize whether or not
it is affected by personal biases
emotions and
outside manipulative views that's why i
constantly stress out the importance of
self-awareness
we live in a time where people are
constantly fighting for our attention
and they will say anything to win it a
self-aware critical thinker needs to
battle his own
float perception and deeply scrutinize
his or her personal issues
in order to be capable of forming a
reasoned and clear view on a topic
critical thinking is rational thinking
that involves critique
what this means is that you need to be
able to think rationally based on
information collected by your
environment
but at the same time question your own
judgment meaning
avoid limiting beliefs and biases in
order to form the most ideal version of
truth possible
truth is quite precious especially in a
time where truth is being manipulated
and concealed for personal gain
during such times critical thinking
gives a bit of control over truth
and the ability to be constantly ready
for the things to come
never stop cultivating it
hey guys this video is sponsored by
datacamp
datacamp is an amazing online platform
that makes it easy to build data
analytical skills at your own pace
with great interactive courses i'm
really proud actually of this
sponsorship because
datacamp is a platform i have used in
the past and it really helped me improve
my skills in programming languages like
sql and python
i have studied electrical engineering
and business so
learning to analyze and manipulate data
was a huge part of my studies and work
anybody who is in the specific domain
will find data camps course is simply
incredible
but even if you're not part of the
technology sector
experimenting and immersing yourself in
this kind of programming can help you
think better
data analysis requires a very structured
way of thinking
and it also helps you develop advanced
analytical skills
as a thinker and a writer i realized
that my involvement in programming
and data analysis has helped me
enormously it has helped me
think creatively properly evaluate the
way i write
and also optimize the structure of my
thinking processes
any person who considers him or herself
a critical thinker
can benefit immensely from such practice
so
you know data can be the best place to
start
if you want to get started use the link
in the description below
and check out the first chapter of any
data cam course
you like for free thanks for watching
see you soon adrian out